qu'ils me regardent mais justement il ya
ton bouquin et ben voilà c'est un bon
enchaînement bons enchaînements merci
guy il a fait tous les enchaînements de
bruyckere pendant trente ans maintenant
que les miens c'est quand même très
appréciable alors donc ce bouquin
mémoire dutreux mère aimait heureux chez
stock
alors c'est un livre passionnant c'est
une succession d'allers retours en train
un passé lointain plus proche passé et
puis aussi le présent où tu parles de
ton enfance tu parles de ta mère la
première phrase est tout à fait
incroyable je n'ai pas rêvé
j'ai bien vu ma mère frappé mon père
avec un marteau budget que j'ai écrit
cette phrase il rit une heure du matin
je n'ai pas fumé du cannabis
ouais rien et l image m'est revenue et
j'ai deux ans et demi la dengue en jeu
je vois ça et personne ne peut me
l'avoir raconté non parce qu'il n'y a
pas de quoi l'argent vente est oui
aussi très très fort c'est à dire
qu'elle lui donne des coups de marteau
est ce qu'on apprend c'est qu'en fait il
est il affirme t-on peru ça c'est le
début non monsieur
c'est vrai que ça s'appelle mémoire
d'outre-mer parce que de voir le jeu de
monde me plaisait pas ça se passe en
algérie
et puis que jamais envie j'ai beaucoup
parlé de ma mère en riant j'avais envie
de raconter la vraie histoire j'avais
envie de me présenter c'est à marthe
villalonga dans le caucase noah c'est un
mushi un nom et c'est beaucoup plus dur
que ça je m'en vais te dire que je vois
ma mère tous les jours ou presque sur ce
moment parce qu'elle est pas bien et que
voilà je sais je
je n'oublie rien je pardonne alors tu tu
raconte l'histoire donc elle tape sur
ton père après ils finissent quand même
par par se séparer et elle se met en
ménage avec un homme évidemment que tu
as envie de tuer parce qu'il peut ce qui
t'a pris aussi a eu envie de bruit et
vitalité appris ta mère et toi tu es au
milieu comme ça en plus ya pas beaucoup
d espace vous êtes tous dans la même
chambre gènes dont tu les entends faire
l'amour et lui cette salle emmerdes
d'avoir le mot mme cayla qui particulier
si je suis l'objet de confidences dont
je me passerais bien à l'âge de 20 ans
ces moments elle te raconte ses
histoires de cul mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même incroyable et donc à un
moment tu peux regretter un ca tue
plante un couteau dans la porte à
hauteur du ventre du mec quoi s'il avait
été là c'est lui qui aurait pris deux
coups de couteau mais j'ai appris la
violence parce que j'étais cerné par la
violence
sas tabasser je suis pas comme ça du
tout je le dis on n'en livre j'ai
remplacé les coûts par des mots ouais
c'est plus gracieux alors tu es mis en
pension et là tu découvres fine mouche
une institutrice
on peut dire pour résumer la situation
elle tu apprends l'égalité la liberté la
fraternité les droits de l'homme et elle
fait toit un droit de l'hommiste en fait
oui déjà règlement ben je répète la même
chose mais avec un peu plus de
vocabulaire
ouais voilà sept ans la messe était dite
et cette fine mouche qui t'a tout a pris
finalement enfin quitter appris en tous
les cas le contraire parce que ta mère
tu l'avais après livre tu l'as tu l'a
plus jamais revu et tu jamais j'aurais
pu faire un effort moi même d'ailleurs
je suis posé la question impossible
busquets elles deux elles tu as
tellement marqué pourquoi t'as pas tout
fait pour la retrouver
je m'engueule moi même par choix alors
c'est vrai qu'à la maison c'est terrible
parce que ya un racisme ambiant 1
on tape pour taper c'est à dire qu'on ne
tape pas juste pour corriger
tu dis ma mère à l'htap pour taper et
puis elle te raconte ses histoires de
cul ces histoires un ultime donc c'est
pour pour un enfant c'est difficile
après quand on est adulte d'oublier tout
ça mais c'est vrai que viol conjugal par
exemple c'est une chose qui fait horreur
et moi qui me fait horreur et puis cette
sorte de bouillie de négligence
affective que ma mère avait vis-à-vis de
moi quand je lui lisais mais rédac
voilà mes dissertations et sert à bassam
a poursuivi longtemps ce qui fait que
par exemple quand je lis des textes je
vais en écrire à ma femme si elle ne
porte pas assez d'attention je vois le
fantôme de ma mère s'interpose lieu et
je suis d'une susceptibilité amoureuse
un peu gonflant sûrement pour pour les
personnes qui vivent avec moi mais je
pense que ma mère je sens ce moment
parce qu'elle me dit les choses qu'elle
aurait dû me dire plus tôt et voilà elle
a attendu d'être au bout de sa vie pour
avouer elle même et je bondis cédé
faisant dix premières années ils sont
les plus longs mais je pense qu'elle
portait en elle et qu' il y avait aussi
celle la présence de son mari qui la
cheville et revenaient même embrassés
dans mon lit le soir le temps était
compté
il y avait tout ça ce qui est écrit dans
le bouquin c'est le mal que son mari et
elle 10,2 ton père c'est à dire que sans
avait sans arrêt c'est la propagande la
propagande alors quand tu le vois le
pauvre de ton souvent tu voi jésus tu
tombes sur lui mais mais ils ont cassé
l'on détruise d'un brave type et benoît
en bas il a été il a manqué un tout
petit peu d'énergie car moi à sa place
j'aurais tout fait avec un fils comme
moi j'aurais tout fait pour je vais pas
laisser passer
j'aurais pris le gosse main à sa place
il a pas fait alors tenté si bien qu'à
l'âge de 12 ans tu as envie de te
suicider à constantine lefa mieux ponk
est sûre le les gorges du rhumel le pont
suspendu qu'on appelle le pont des
suicides est aussi d'ailleurs à un
moment tu tu vas sur ce pont et tu as
envie que je t'ai pas partir avec jamais
hanté pendant longtemps après en 50 vous
partez de d'algérie pour arriver en
métropole 3 tours fc d'approché gérard
philipe et alors ce qui est terrible
c'est que sur le chemin de marseille à
paris ils font quand même un pèlerinage
à vichy à dire que c'est quand même
je dis d'ailleurs dans le livre pour ces
pétainiste convaincu vigie c'était
lourde
ouais c'est ça et amère à avaler la
photo de pétain dans son sac quoi bon
vieux vu un oui et là toi tu flippes
complètement tussauds matisse une espèce
de dépression et c'est un toubib qui dit
faut qu'il fasse du théâtre
extraordinaire fut le théâtre genre de
nos fruits je tiens à les féliciter
c'est vrai parce que il fallait
ouh ouh théâtre ou la leucémie on savait
pas très bien
ben c'est mieux le théâtre ouais la
demande lui à la leucémie
j'en ai sorti avec beaucoup de courage
famille nathalie ouais je savais très
bien sorti c'est vraiment un exemple
alors voilà donc à 17 ans tu débarques
rue blanche à 17 ans et demi tu mets en
scène et tu joues l'arlequin de marivaux
donc voilà c'est à dire que dès que tu
arrives à paris tu es le théâtre ouais
le théâtre le théâtre jouée le public
les gens tout de suite j'ai compris que
c'est ça qui allait me sauver cette
communication forte avec avec l'autre
ouais alors ta mère c'est terrible parce
que donc à l'époque tu dormais encore
chez elle et puis tu rentrais et un soir
où tu rentres avec une arme de retard je
m'étais attardé je suis là vieux h sur
la gauche française
j'étais la soute de la griffe française
j'avais vu un b avec les copains et
combien on habitait une maison
j'ai raté mon dernier train et c'est un
copain qui m'a ramené en scooter et la
clé elle n'y était pas il faisait moins
15 et elle m'a laissé tas d'or et toute
la nuit il est à l'intérieur des travers
la fenêtre pour voir si je grelottais
bien il le lendemain je suis parti pour
un jour pour toujours voilà mais c'est
quand même quand tu es née elle a dit
mon dieu qu'il est vilain on dirait un
petit juif
pardon c'est une méchanceté est alors
aujourd'hui tu la regardes un peu
inconscient ouais je suis même pas sûr
qu'elle soit vraiment méchant elle se
rend pas compte de ce qu elle dit des
horreurs parfois ou où elle a dit des
horreurs qu'elle a maintenant elle me
dit aujourd'hui elle te dis que tu te
dis que tu as barbe ça te va vachement
bien que tu avais je suis très beau avec
la barbe
toi tu lui fais ses menus
oui parce qu'elle voulait plus manger
laisser mourir
je vais situe même manger vie ça le
paradoxe est que j venu son père
maintenant on vient les parents de ses
parents au bout d'un moment ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que tu as trouvé
son équilibre en faisant le contraire de
ce qu'elle disait finalement oui oui oui
j'ai fait tout à l'envers
les morts de trop manger leur joie
c'est jose cote